[Music]
where the hell you at
I'm on time for pageant brightness I
mean what are you wearing you like
you're going to the pen check hi my name
is Jim and I only have 30 minutes in my
schedule these are for you
we're gonna learn how to walk heels you
must got me after somebody Hills mama
why can't you walk in heels this is just
like an excuse that you don't because
you're too lazy and you don't know oh no
I had my foot right over my for lift
when I was 19 years old where and I have
a left-side nerve damage from pumpkins
bad ass because I set their patron eight
on the wrong spot well since you don't
know how to do this little dance walk in
there
we're going front to your back team what
kind of walk is that your walk has
changed a lot since you were all saved
last your turn do it exactly like I just
did when you were younger they used to
say the olden days no you got to keep up
with the newer days negative yes it is
your turn do it exactly like I just said
show them what you really are
she loves hanging out with her daughter
especially Alana
she has 43 kids 43 plus 1,500 pounds hey
let's give it up
and you three kids up one foot in front
of other one in front the other another
you're going way too fast so you're
getting all those surgeries you did not
think need your feet fixed
[Music]
you